- 'Cause they're actually from--
- They're expired?
- 1999?
- Shut up.
- [Voiceover] All food consumed
was done so voluntarily.
BuzzFeed does not condone
the eating of Episode 1
snacks from 1999.
Do not attempt at home.
- This is box is faded (beep).
Never a good thing when you're
trying to eat a food source.
- Wait, let's do the math, 1999.
So these are 16 years old.
- I'm gonna eat it.
(laughing)
Pretty dusty.
- This has Jar Jar Binks all over it.
He's literally the worst.
- I think at the time
they actually thought
people would like Jar Jar Binks
before the movie came out.
They were wrong
in the biggest way possible.
- (laughs) Look at the color of this.
- Holy (beep).
- Dude, it's like parchment paper.
- From the (beep) libraries
of Alexandria, dude.
Are you kidding me? Oh my God.
- Maybe I'm rethinking that I want to--
- That is gross!
- It's looks like Yoda took
a (beep) on this paper.
(laughing)
- What's on the paper?
- [Man] Oh my God.
- No, it tastes fine.
- [Man] It smells terrible,
are you serious?
- Hmm. Smells nice.
- I don't know about that.
It's like nice with a
little bit of rotten.
- Oh!
It smells like grandpa's shoes.
- I think you ought to try it.
- You ate it? Ooh, ooh!
- That's a terrible idea, don't eat it.
(laughing)
- [Woman] Tastes like
watermelon, kind of.
- [Man] It's actually pretty
good once you get goin'.
- Are you really eating it?
Ugh (laughs).
- It's like if you marinated a watermelon
piece of candy from today in
an ashtray for a little while.
- (laughs) That is exactly what it is.
- I don't know, I don't know about this.
- Dust (blows out air).
Ancient artifacts.
- The detail on these gellies are amazing.
- Spared no expense back in 1999.
We're getting (beep) now.
- Oh, is that Anakin? I would
love to eat his stupid face.
- Oh God, these are like rocks.
- Oh, the colors are gone.
- Whoa.
- I could probably kill somebody with this
if I got it going.
- Yeah, oh my gosh, I
can't even squeeze it.
- They're all brown.
- See, these smell weird
but they smell fruity still.
I betcha they have a ton of preservatives.
- I bet you these are still good.
- These can't be good, what are you
talking about?
- [Woman] I bet you they are.
- These were supposed to be...
- Just kidding, I can't chew it.
- Oh!
- You gotta use your molars.
- I feel like it'll pull out my filling.
- It might.
(laughing)
- Very odd flavor.
- It actually tasted like an eraser.
- This just tastes like soap.
- What's wrong with you?
- I feel like 15 years of dust packaging
in my mouth right now.
(intense music)